y el día comenzó muy tempranito con un
evento en el que los protagonistas
fueron los pescadores artesanales que no
forman parte de las conversaciones ni de
la conferencia oficial esta
invisibilidad es la que denunció un
grupo de representantes de varios
continentes en un evento que como bien
dije reunió a varios de estos pescadores
artesanales ellos independientemente de
su origen
denuncian o hacen un llamado para que
los gobernantes y los organizadores de
estas cumbres y conferencias los
incluyan en las conversaciones y en la
toma de decisiones porque les afectan de
primera mano como bien dijo uno de los
representantes de pescadores artesanales
de honduras del pueblo garífuna de
honduras ese océano del que tanto se
habla en estas conferencias y al que
supuestamente tanto quieren proteger los
gobernantes es donde los pescadores
artesanales viven y dónde de dónde sacan
su manera de subsistir escuchemos
algunos de sus mensajes
no se nos hacen consultas y nosotros
sabemos los tiempos del mar como decía
un compañero somos los científicos que
estamos ahí sin título pero si conocemos
las temporadas del mar o serie de
portales que el internacional no sería
importante que los medios
internacionales muestren al mundo entero
como nosotros podemos estar organizados
y sobre todo que la sociedad mundial
pueda entender de una vez por todas qué
es lo que realmente está sucediendo en
el planeta y de contextos no planeados
viendo los compañeros de otros países
aquí todos tenemos el mismo problema
pero tenemos algo en común como dicen
muchos que vivimos del mar dependemos
del mar y nosotros las autoridades deben
de ver que nosotros también alimentamos
al mundo
no solo no sólo nosotros sino que
nuestro producto lo que capturamos todo
es para el mundo es para todas las
personas incluso para ellos mismos que
hacen las políticas
también pude hablar con un patricio del
pueblo mapuche en chile que pide que se
trabaje en conjunto con la sabiduría
ancestral para poder llegar a soluciones
en pro del avance y en pro de la
naturaleza por su parte el presidente de
la asociación de la confederación perdón
africana de pescadores artesanales dijo
estar convencido de que la salud de los
océanos
depende al 100% de los pescadores
artesanales y que la durabilidad de las
pesquerías mundiales es decir la
cantidad de peces disponible en el
océano para que nosotros podamos
consumirlo de manera sostenible depende
de estos pescadores artesanales todos
ellos que pudieron venir aquí a lisboa
porque fueron invitados por una
organización privada ya que no estaban
invitados oficialmente hablaron de estas
cosas frente al ministro de medio
ambiente de costa rica- frank staten
back que estaba presente y al que
exigieron que se les incluya en estas
conversaciones y sobre todo que se hagan
mención de la pesca artesanal y del
papel esencial que ésta tiene y de los
obviamente en la declaración en que
saldrá de esta conferencia de los
océanos aquí en lisboa